let's hear from some of the people in
our audience we are taking calls today
via discord you can join the david
pakman show discord
at davidpakman.com
discord it is a great place to be
let's go first here to
let's go to stephanie from richardson
texas which has just announced they are
opening everything they are stopping
masking
they are doing so many different things
stephanie what's going on down there
hi can you hear me yes i can wonderful
excellent i
love your show i discovered you during
quarantine i just want to start off by
saying that
thank you for taking my call pleasure um
yeah i'm so glad you took my call this
is a
first time i've done something like this
and i am calling to speak on um
being absolutely beside myself for uh
the unmasking mandate and i'm a little
freaked out actually
so so here was my question on this
stephanie my
my belief was in a segment i did when
when the news broke about this
i said this is crazy irresponsible you
know only seven percent of texans are
vaccinated it's just far too early
however on i i have a sense that
the people that don't care about the
guidelines we're already ignoring them
in texas anyway and that people that do
are going to keep wearing masks anyway
like is is there some truth to that
yeah that's actually my hope i really
i'm i'm hoping that
as startling as the news was i'm really
hoping that
we will maintain as we have been because
right as you've seen in a lot of the
reports it is a lot like that people who
aren't gonna mask
aren't gonna mask even though there was
a mandate in place
and those of us who've chosen to keep
doing that we'll keep doing that my only
my only real concern is that um
the uh our texas education agency that's
run by
a software person not an educator
hopefully will follow the guidelines and
keep the mass mandates in place at
school because i do have a daughter in
middle school so
i'm really hoping that that will be the
they'll follow the guidelines and be
smart about it because obviously you
know
a lot of parents are concerned about
that but yeah i mean that's kind of my
hope too though
that is that um a lot of the people who
are
continuing to follow the guidelines will
keep doing that i don't think those of
us who've been doing it
also oh yeah it's just not you know i'm
still not gonna go to restaurants i'm
still not gonna go you know unmasked so
it's just like i'm hoping the rest of us
are gonna be in the same boat
basically now when you say that a lot of
people were ignoring the mass guidelines
anywhere
anyway in some states with mask mandates
if you go into a business without a mask
you get kicked out in texas is it more
of like a look the other way type of
thing
yes yeah basically yeah it's kind of
like upsetting because i've been
in places that have like you know the
mass mandate
requirement on the door but then i go in
there and i see people without a mask
and it's fortunately not like
it's less often than not i guess i
should say but it's like when i see
someone i'll turn around just go the
other way and you know
do my like i was mostly at the grocery
store and i'll just shop in another
aisle but
yeah it's it's not i'm not seeing any of
those things that like people post on
social media or whatever about people
freaking out about masks you know in
stores they don't really do that because
don't really
the store owners don't do a lot to
enforce it so it's like you know that's
a little frustrating but again like i
said it's not
happening all the time so it's good and
i don't see any real drama but i just
kind of
go in a different aisle and continue my
shopping and let me ask you this
are there places where if you go in with
a mask
you are looked at like you're the crazy
one yeah absolutely
actually it's um funny because i mostly
i do research and i shop at low hours
and i
at low capacity hours or whatever and i
um and i uh go places that have a
mandate but my husband goes to a place
locally that is an independently owned
business
and the guy does not require you wear a
mask and he says
he'll wear his mask in there and the guy
will yell at him like take it off he's
like i'm not gonna
do that see that's crazy that's crazy
take it off
it's like he's kind of half joking but
not really but he knows
it's like a business owner he knows so
he's not gonna like you know
he's gonna my husband's gonna do what
he's gonna do but he's like i thought i
wouldn't go in there
right right right right right right so
it's like it is it's there's people
they're just like it's just it's so
crazy and there's people that just like
it's like i my whole attitude this whole
time has been it's like the least
thing you can do you know it's just it's
the minimum requirements where
yeah it's such an easy thing it's like
you just you know okay you want to open
businesses make sense but they're just
wearing a mask is so easy
well listen stephanie thanks for the
update on what's going on down there and
stay safe thanks you too i appreciate it
all right
stephanie from texas great to hear from
her
one of our sponsors is privacy a free
service that protects your credit and
debit card
i use privacy every time i buy something
online i installed the app
on my phone and the privacy desktop
browser extension
now when i pay for anything privacy
autofills a virtual
credit card number the money's taken out
of my bank account i don't have to give
out my real card number or banking info
to anyone
you can create and delete the virtual
cards anytime
i especially love it for free trials
because i can destroy the virtual card
number
as soon as i give it to the company and
i know i won't be charged in the future
privacy also has a feature called shared
cards
which makes it easy to split payments
with friends parents can manage a
virtual card for their kid
with spending limits businesses can
manage virtual cards
for employees to use for company
expenses there are premium plans
available but privacy's regular service
is totally free to use
and right now they'll give you five
dollars just for signing up when you go
to privacy.com
pacman the link is underneath this video